happiness is typically defined by asking
people about whether they're happy and
whether they're satisfied with their
life sometimes it's called subjective
well-being and sometimes it's called
life satisfaction sometimes it's called
happiness and that's because all three
of those aspects are in the items that
constitute that question and what the
research on happiness tends to show is
that a meaningful life and a connected
life are critically important if you
have no money if you're destitute that
that makes you unhappy if you're
diseased that makes you unhappy but
above those minimum requirements having
a meaningful life that also is connected
to others turns out to be fairly
critical and when you think about it at
the moment of your death it doesn't
really matter how much material stuff
you leave behind when I was young I was
in a very bad to automobiles it and I
had that moment where I thought about my
life to that point and I can tell you
that all the achievements all the
material items meant absolutely nothing
that thing that I thought lasts about
were the individuals who I loved and
that was a small number and and my only
concern at that point was really just
with with them and that's something I
think most people if not everyone goes
through at the end and it's you know in
some ways it was a gift from me to
realized that when I still had a
lifetime with them and I think if we can
realize that then that contributes to
greater happiness as well
human nature is defined variously by
different authors and scientists so it's
worth trying to define what I mean by it
some describe human nature I think what
you mean by human nature as the genetics
as what's biologically determined and
that is not how I'm using the term human
nature to me is why what is our nature
as humans as simple as that
Donald Hebb a psychologist in the middle
of the 20th century at McGill University
asked whether nature or nurture genes or
environment were more important to
behavior said that's a little bit like
asking whether the length or the width
of a rectangle contributes more to the
area of the rectangle it's boats so we
are genetic machines but those genes
have been selected by environments by
cultures they promote adaptive behavior
and environments and in cultures they're
deeply interactive when it comes to mind
and behavior with the environment and
with culture and so I think about human
nature as what is the biological
machinery we have what can we do
socially and culturally and how do those
combine to create the mind and behavior
that we see in everyday life
I wrote the book for two reasons and I
wrote the book with bill Patrick Liu is
a wonderful wonderful friend and
colleague now and so I'll say we wrote
the book for two reasons one reason was
because I think loneliness is babby
misunderstood and that's to the
detriment of 60 million people in
America it's about 20 percent of the
individuals filled only to any one point
in time and that's a lot of people to
have miserable for perhaps unnecessary
reasons and I thought the science was at
a point where we could perhaps with an
intelligent book help them but there was
a deeper reason and that is that it's a
book about social neuroscience it's a
book about who are we as humans and I
think the focus on the solitary
individual and about us as cognitive
machines as solitary computers is wrong
I mean fundamentally I think it's the
wrong idea we are not solitary computers
we are information processing devices
but we're much more like the Internet
and that the capacity comes from our
ability to connect with other similar
devices out there and to reconfigure
that's where the real power of computing
is today including human computing but
that's a very very different depiction
and so I thought it was worth raising
that point of discussion for a broad
audience and I hope the book does